elles sont souvent velu et certains les
trouvent repoussante
les araignées du musée royal de
l'ontario ne plaisent pas à tout le
monde mais leur venin pourrait renfermer
la solution à plusieurs de nos problèmes
afin de mieux comprendre ce que contient
la substance le musée a décidé de mettre
ses pensionnaires à contribution deux
fois par jour les visiteurs sont conviés
à une démonstration hors du commun
devant les regards attentifs les
araignées sont d'abord endormi à l'aide
de monoxyde de carbone puis immobilisé
sur un plateau pour percer la reynie
mais juste pour qu'on 3 et pour tenir
ses pattes et ils sont encore en place
mais là utilisent si choc électrique
pour sceller la production devenait une
fois la décharge terminé le précieux
liquide et recueillie congelé puis
envoyés dans un laboratoire de
l'université de l'utah
les chercheurs s'intéressent
particulièrement ont composé chimique du
venin qui ont un potentiel dans
plusieurs domaines industriels ça peut
être médicale
beaucoup de choses qui aident pour
calmer la douleur l'extraction du venin
est un procédé indolore pour les
araignées mais peu efficace souvent une
seule goutte ni recueilli tous les
spécimens d'araignée qui font partie de
l'exposition aux sont inoffensifs
malgré tout leur venin intéresse les
chercheurs il dit qu'on ne doit pas
gaspiller venait mais plutôt l'utilisé
surtout que la recherche sur le sujet
est devenu de plus en plus importante
ces dernières années qui ici mathieu
simard radio canada toronto